-My guest tonight is the mayor
of the great city of Atlanta
Please welcome to the show
Mayor Keisha Lance Bottoms
Mayor, thank you so much
for making time for us today
I want to start by a speec
you gave last week.
You spoke both as a mayor
and as a mother.
It was passionate.
It felt very honest.
How hard has it been for you
to address your city
in this really trying time
-You know, what you got from
me on Friday, Seth,
was every emotion
that I've been feeling
over the past week or so.
And you got it unfiltered
on Friday.
And like so many people,
we all have so many emotions
about this.
And whether it's watching it
feeling it in ourselves,
or watching it with our kids
or our communities,
I had a platform Friday
just to express what I fel
and that frustration.
And I can tell you, I didn't
plan on saying any of that
I didn't know what I was going
to say when I said it on Friday.
And in fact, after I was done,
I couldn't remember
what I had said.
And I think, you know,
it really speaks to
how built up and just
how full I felt on Friday.
But I'm just grateful that i
resonated with so many people.
-You have made the point,
which I think a lot
of people would share,
that the president
should stop talking.
When he talks, it's not
particularly helpful.
He obviously spoke last nigh
about the need
for law enforcement to dominat
the people in the streets.
How do you both
protect your city
and communicate with your
law enforcement officers
as to how to move forward with
what's happening in your city?
-This is a really
delicate balance,
and ironically,
just as I was walking in her
to record with you,
I was speaking with
my 18-year-old son,
and he was telling me --
showing me another video,
and his frustration.
And what I was trying to
articulate to him was,
when I said on Friday,
"I can't protect you,"
what I was expressing was that
our law enforcement
officers are tired.
They are beyond exhausted
at this point.
They're working 18-hour shifts
to try and maintain some commo
stability in our cities.
And we understand the
frustration and the anger,
and all of these emotions
that people are experiencing
right now.
It's understandable.
But on the other side of this,
you also have
many of our officers,
especially in Atlanta,
who are African-American men
who are experiencing
these same emotions.
They're experiencing it becaus
of who they are and the children
that they also are raising
in this country.
And...it's a difficult balance
Showing that support, asking
our officers to show restraint
and compassion, while also
trying to maintain
some type of order
in our streets
when we have so many
peaceful protesters.
But we have so many other people
who are just attempting
to be disrupters right now
-You and the chief of police
made the decision
to fire two police officer
after watching video
of their behavior.
How do you balance both
supporting police officers
and making sure you remove
the bad actors
within the police force?
Because it does strike me that
what everybody wants to believe,
what all citizens
want to believe,
that if there are bad
police officers,
they'll be removed
from the force.
Is that hopefully the messag
that comes across
when you make
a decision like that?
-It certainly is.
And the reality is that,
had this incident happened
last week,
we probably would have taken
a little more time
to look at what happened
with this incident
and with these officers and --
but what we've seen over
the past week is,
we don't have the luxury
of time anymore.
We have to act swiftly,
especially when it's very clea
that our officers
are not behaving
appropriately.
And I think that is what's to be
expected or should be expected
from so many of us
across the country now.
And it's also a culture shif
for many of our police officers,
that they have to understand
that they won't always
have another chance
to get it right.
And again, it's a shift
that we saw the Obama/Bide
administration making
when they left the handboo
on 21st Century Policing.
It's the same handbook --
it's a handbook
that they probably left
alongside the pandemic handboo
that the Trump administratio
never picked up.
But one of the major pillars
of 21st Century Policing
is that you create trustworthy
relationships with communities
on the front end.
And so, you do things like
we're doing in Atlanta,
where you have a center of hop
where our police recruits go
and volunteer and spend time
with the kids
so their first interaction
with them
is not a negative interaction.
Where you have
implicit bias training.
And there were several pillars
to this program.
And we've done a very good job
in Atlanta, by and large,
in following those pillars
But it's got to happen
across the country.
And it's got to come from
a national level
in terms of expectations.
-Someone else who spoke
passionately on stage with you
last Friday was the rapper
Killer Mike.
He had incredibly
inspiring words.
How does it come to pass
that you end up with a rappe
on stage with you?
-Well, again,
these relationships
are existing relationships
The irony, Killer Mike, T.I.
and I all went
to the same high school.
I was a little ahead
of both of them,
because I'm a little
older than them.
But we bleed Atlanta.
We love Atlanta.
And so, Killer Mike and T.I.
worked on my transition
when I went into office.
But -- and I could probably name
ten other celebrities
in Atlanta who've reached ou
and said,
"What is it that I could d
to help?"
So, this is not the first time
that Killer Mike
has been at the table with u
setting policy for our city,
and having these real
conversations about
where we need to go
and how we need to approach it
Because again,
I look at everything
as the lens of a mother.
And I know I can say something
ten different ways
and all my kids hear,
"Whomp, whomp, whomp."
But if T.I. says it,
if Killer Mike says it,
it's going to translate,
and it's going to be heard
and it's going to be felt
differently.
And so on Friday, when
everything started to unrave
in Atlanta, I didn't have
a very clear picture
of what we needed to do.
But I knew the voices that
needed to be heard.
And that's why you saw
Killer Mike, and Bernice King,
and T.I., and Joe Beasley
and some other community leaders
standing with me.
-And I should make it clea
that while he's
one of my favorite rappers, he's
also an incredible activist.
And I think that
really came through
when he was on stage with you.
You mentioned your older son
who just graduated high school
in quarantine,
is that correct?
-That's right.
-You also --
one of your younger sons is,
I believe
you've referred to it
as "Club Quarantine."
He's learning how to deeja
through this time?
-He is and he loves it.
He has a little corner
set up in my office.
And now he even stays up
all night like a deejay.
When I get up at 6:00 in
the morning to take a shower
he's taking a shower
to go to bed.
So, we're going to have to und
some quarantine behaviors.
But yeah, it -- that's -- that's
been the upside of this.
-All right.
Give all your kids our best.
And give our best
to the city of Atlanta.
And best of luck
with everything.
We really appreciate
the work you're doing.
-And thank you so much for jus
giving me a platform
to talk about this.
And I appreciate
your dedicating time
to these very real discussions
about where we are
in this country.
I appreciate you.
-All right.
Thank you, Mayor.
-Thank you.